das ist das brandenburger tor
aber dieses steht nicht in berlin
sondern in potsdam hauptstadt des
bundeslandes brandenburg
hier geht es beschaulich zu im advent
ist die stadt besonders herausgeputzt in
potsdam haben zahlreiche preußischen
herrscher ihre spuren hinterlassen
preußen war einer der wichtigsten
europäischen staaten vom achtzehnten
jahrhundert bis 1918 das alte
stadtschloss aus jener zeit wurde wieder
aufgebaut ebenso wie der palast
barberini potsdam pflegt sein erle den
einfluss der verschiedenen könige in
potsdam kann man natürlich bis heute am
stadtbild der nachvollziehen es war
immer residenzstadt bis 1918
das heißt also diese stadt sollte eine
schöne sein
im prinzip ist das erscheinungsbild der
stadt durch ihre vergangenheit eine die
sehr heimisch wirkt auf viele und das
möchten viele bewahren und wieder
errichten
das holländische viertel mitten in
potsdam es geht auch friedrich wilhelm
den ersten zurück den sogenannten
preußischen soldatenkönigs er war ein
großer anhänger der niederlande
und weil er vom wissen des landes
profitieren wollte der handwerker und
baumeister nach potsdam ein
so entstand das größte zusammenhängende
bauensemble im holländischen stil in
deutschland ich dachte was ist denn hier
so besonders aber der soldaten klinik
hat es auch immer noch bei mir 250 jahre
später ein gefühl erreicht was er damals
schon schaffen wollte nämlich dass man
sich hier heimisch fühlt bis heute wird
hier zu weihnachten eine niederländische
tradition gefeiert
an einem adventswochenende kommt
sinterklaas in das viertel
dann zeigen niederländische handwerker
ihr angebot und die holländische version
dessen nikolaus zieht durch die straßen
nicht niederländisch aber auch eine
institution der stadt die confiserie
felicitas in der adventszeit herrscht
hier hochbetrieb
die konditoren backen potsdam typisches
gebäck und kreieren pralinen
besonders beliebt ist eine wüste aus
schokolade sie zeigt die berühmte
preußenkönigin luise die figuren sind
natürlich mit der geschichte von potsdam
eng verbunden dadurch dass diese
wirklich nur sehr sehr positive figur
ist wird sie auch noch sehr gerne
gekauft verschenkt
heute ist potsdam eine moderne stadt
aber das alte preußen lebt überall ein
bisschen weiter sogar auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt dort können besucher
laternen und lametta in einer ganz
bestimmten farbe bewundern
preußisch blau wird meistens mit den
uniformen als allererstes assoziiert der
preußischen armee
denn unter dem soldatenkönig wurden die
farben der vorher vielen uniform faden
vereinheitlicht nämlich zu preußischblau
und potsdam sind blauer lichterglanz ist
eigentlich der einzige weihnachtsmarkt
in deutschland der mit blauer arbeitet
ein blauer lichterglanz
einst war das als marketing der stadt
gedacht inzwischen ist es zur tradition
geworden sputen besitzer greifen das
blau bei ihren ständen auf
[Musik]
und sogar die schlittschuhbahn am
luisenplatz ist bläulich eingefärbt aber
was denken die besucher darüber der
bläuliche glanz also ich finde sehr
ästhetisch sehr schön er hat irgendwie
sowas sehr weiches mir gefällt es ganz
gut es gibt ganz viele sterne und laos
letztes meine lieblingsfarbe letztens
erst mal was ganz anderes
zu hause würde es nicht machen aber hier
sieht vielleicht nicht schlecht aus ich
mag es eher klassisch ich finde die
blaulichter immer sehr schön
also es gibt den ganz immer noch so eine
besondere atmosphäre
neben den weißen licht denn die man in
häusern dran sind der weihnachtsmarkt
zeigt potsdam wie es heute ist das blaue
licht wirkt modernen und erinnert an die
lange tradition der stadt